making a big hollywood blockbuster ain't
cheap but how expensive is too expensive
which popular superhero just couldn't
save the day or rather the opening
weekend keep watching to find out
sony has been trying to turn
ghostbusters into a franchise for three
decades with little success thanks in
part to inflated expectations the
original ghostbusters made 295 million
dollars worldwide in 1984 about 789
million dollars worldwide in today's
dollars five years later ghostbusters 2
made 215 million dollars worldwide over
480 million dollars worldwide today
so when sony finally made a new
ghostbusters after the series spent
nearly 30 years in development hell they
apparently figured the new version would
land in that 500 to 800 million dollar
range that may explain why they spent a
bloated 144 million dollars on 2016's
ghostbusters answer the call the big
problem is that it wasn't a sequel
featuring characters we knew and loved
but a reboot with a whole new cast that
typically doesn't work out and answer
the call was no exception the film
finished with 229 million dollars
worldwide not bad for a comedy in modern
hollywood but not nearly enough to
warrant a sequel instead sony apparently
learned their financial lessons and made
2021's ghostbusters afterlife for only
half the budget of answer the call
allowing it to turn a profit you are a
genius paddy i'm a ghostbuster
battleship is considered one of the
biggest box office bombs of the past
decade and not even rihanna's legion of
fans would argue with that but it's not
for the reason you might think
battleship wasn't a bomb because it
didn't make money it bummed because it
didn't make enough money battleship
scored 313 million dollars worldwide in
2012 not bad for an insanely bad sci-fi
film based on a board game that was
mostly due to its 248 million dollar
international gross but it had the
misfortune of debuting just after
marvel's the avengers which went on to
become one of the highest grossing films
of all time the crazy part battleship
and the avengers had almost the same
budget the avengers cost 225 million
dollars about only five million dollars
more than battleships 220 million
dollars yep universal almost spent the
same amount on friggin battleship as
marvel did on the avengers according to
the new yorker battleship was green lit
with a 150 million dollar budget which
would have allowed it to turn a profit
but after the production ran into issues
the studio had to throw tens of millions
of dollars down the drain to try and fix
it
just because a character is a household
name doesn't mean he's a box office draw
thus while superman is probably the most
famous superhero of all time he's no
longer the most bankable at the box
office though he was once in 1978
superman the movie made moviegoers
believe a man could fly and made a lot
of money doing it earning 300 million
dollars worldwide about 1.2 billion
today mighty impressive for the man of
steel after the original franchise ended
with a whimper with 1987 superman iv the
quest for peace warner brothers spent
almost two decades trying to figure out
what to do next the rest was 2006's
superman returns which at 232 million
dollars cost a lot more than other
superhero origin stories at the time
2002's spider-man for instance only cost
139 million dollars to make while 2005's
batman begins cost 150 million dollars
superman returns ended up earning 391
million dollars worldwide with
spider-man or batman begins budgets it
would have made money and likely would
have spawned a whole new trilogy just as
those two films did thanks to its
inflated budget though it has been
considered a failure and signaled the
final end of the classic superman
franchise
by 2012 the pirates of the caribbean
franchise had earned about 3.5 billion
dollars across four films pride comes
before the fall so disney johnny depp
director gore verbinski and producer
jerry brockheimer thought their
relationship was a license to print gold
and could do no wrong but the lone
ranger went wrong very very wrong
beginning with the whole idea of
reviving an outdated radio western that
hadn't been popular for decades in
disney's defense they realized the
film's budget was getting out of control
and even shut down production to contain
it it didn't work sources vary with the
final budget estimated to have been
between 225 million dollars and 250
million dollars wherever it landed the
lone ranger would have had to break
records to break even for context the
lone ranger cost about 100 million
dollars more than the first pirates of
the caribbean film despite starring army
hammer who has since been accused of
cannibalism and worse the film still
made 260 million dollars worldwide so
with a smaller budget it could have been
a success but with those costs making a
lone ranger 2 would have been a true
train wreck
thanks to star wars marvel pixar and
disney plus it may seem like the house
that walt built is indestructible this
conveniently ignores the fact that
disney's original live action output has
mostly been a wasteland of box office
bombs including some of the biggest
disappointments of all time in fact
disney's desperation for live-action
movies is probably why they purchased
marvel and lucasfilms in the first place
one disney film that did so so and would
have been a big hit if not for the even
bigger budget was tron legacy tron
bombed in 1982 and while it built a cult
following making a legacy sequel 28
years later to a movie nobody saw in
theaters was a bit of a head scratcher
couple that with the 200 million dollar
price tag and you'd have to wonder
whether mickey lost his marbles smartly
though disney positioned tron legacy as
the must-see holiday blockbuster of 2010
and it mostly worked as the film earned
399 million dollars worldwide at disney
spent just a little bit less there's no
question we would have seen more sequels
as it is though the legacy of tron is a
failure
speaking of waiting three decades to
make an overpriced sequel of a movie
that was a flop to begin with say hello
to 2017's blade runner 2049. the
original blade runner made 39 million
dollars on a 28 million dollar budget
back in 1982 meaning it wasn't a
disaster but was far from a hit still it
has been hailed as a masterpiece by
critics so surely that would translate
into ticket sales 35 years later right
warner brothers bet 185 million dollars
that it would it didn't with 258 million
dollars worldwide the sequel far
exceeded the originals take but didn't
come close to becoming a hit we can
argue all day whether deckard was a
replicant but there's no debate on this
blade runner should not have been
replicated at 185 million dollars
what do you do when your movie's in
production isn't working and you've
already spent a ton of money on it
option a is finishing the film and
hoping for the best option b is dropping
another several million in the hopes of
fixing it warner brothers opted for
option b with justice league and the
result was a mixed bag at the box office
after spending 275 million dollars on
2017's justice league warner brothers
removed director zack snyder replaced
him with problematic avengers director
joss whedon and dumped another 25
million dollars into reshoots bloating
the budget to an incredible 300 million
dollars they still hoped to turn a
profit as batman vs superman had made
872 million dollars worldwide and
justice league was adding wonder woman
flash and aquaman to the film it should
have been a surefire recipe for success
instead fans and critics alike hated the
film bad word of mouth tanked it at the
box office and it limped to a 655
million dollar worldwide gross though it
made a small profit it destroyed the
franchise and earned less than half of
what marvel's the avengers had brought
in five years earlier all in all justice
league was more trainwreck than tentpole
what was it like
coming back
itchy
conventional wisdom says the mummy
franchise was going strong until the
mummy tomb of the dragon emperor bombed
as with most things the conventional
wisdom isn't wrong it's just missing
part of the story yes tomb of the dragon
emperor was also really really bad even
for a franchise that never got much love
from critics however the mummy franchise
made money with every movie the problem
is that the budget on tomb of the dragon
emperor was so much bigger than its
predecessors 1999's the mummy cost 80
million dollars to make while 2001's the
mummy returns cost 98 million dollars
but when tomb of the dragon emperor came
out in 2008 it cost a whopping 175
million dollars tomb of the dragon
emperor actually earned 405 million
dollars worldwide almost the same amount
as each of the previous films but with
the budget twice as high it didn't make
nearly as much money killing the
franchise deader than imotep
harrison ford is one of the 10 highest
grossing movie stars of all time with
career earnings 10 billion dollars
worldwide and that's unadjusted for
inflation however outside of indiana
jones and the kingdom of the crystal
skull and star wars the force awakens
ford hasn't had an above the title hit
since 2000's what lies beneath that
should have changed in 2020 with the
call of the wild key word should the
call of the wild made 62 million dollars
domestically and 107 million dollars
worldwide fairly modest amounts but for
a film about a guy and his dog it did
quite well one massive problem though
20th century fox spent an incredible 125
million dollars to make it blame budget
itis a term for hollywood's inexplicable
inability to make mid-budget movies the
big issue was their decision to use cgi
to create buck the dog which turned what
could have been a modest hit into a 50
million dollar loser
some box office observers argue that
robert downey jr isn't a movie star
outside his signature tony stark role
while there's no denying most of his
15.7 billion worldwide career earnings
come from playing the man in the iron
suit he has proven to be a reliable draw
on films like tropic thunder and the
sherlock holmes movies no his butts in
seats bank ability isn't on par with
leonardo dicaprio or dwayne the rock
johnson but no other movie stars have
that drawing power either it seemed like
downey jr would add to his bankable
resume with 2020s doolittle but instead
that movie turned out to be a titanic
turkey and not a talking one either yet
doolittle actually made 251 million
dollars worldwide about on par with
other live-action kids movies released
in the past 15 years as the sub-genre
has been dominated for more than a
decade by animation the problem somebody
at universal thought it was a good idea
to spend 175 million dollars on
doolittle which is actually more than
iron man 2 cost to make expecting downey
jr to pull mcu numbers in a non-ironman
role was dumb still he might have been
one of the only humans popular enough to
save doolittle from utter destruction
that's not good as far as i'm concerned
i'm the only human you
comedies hit or miss at the box office
as humor doesn't always translate
overseas what's a movie studio to do you
don't spend millions on pricey vfx like
you're making a marvel movie instead you
spend most of its money on the movie
star and hope he can put butts in the
seats unless you're universal that is
bruce almighty with jim carrey's mug
plastered on the poster made 484 million
dollars on an 81 million dollar budget
in 2003 making it not only carries
biggest hit but one of the highest
grossing comedies ever but bruce
almighty worked because of the jim
carrey as god concept not the brand
there was no indication audiences would
show up to steve carell as noah just
because universal slapped almighty on it
welp universal felt otherwise and spent
175 million dollars on the film more
than twice bruce's budget making it the
most expensive comedy ever made to that
point the budget was supposed to be just
140 million dollars but costs ran up
thanks to cgi and live animals
ultimately the film made 174 million
dollars worldwide which wasn't bad for a
comedy sequel that didn't even star the
original actor but was a disaster of
biblical proportions based on the budget
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you